[Music]
on today's show we talked to an awesome
dad who's working three jobs to support
his family but he's not connecting and
he's exhausted we also talked to the mom
of a 15 year old daughter who's having
sex and she doesn't know what to say to
her we talk to an exhausted mother who's
trying to balance and doesn't know that
balance is a myth stay tuned
[Music]
what is up this is john with the dr john
dalone's show
we are taking on the world
not really we're not very tough we are
taking on the work that just sounded
cool but we're not really hope you're
doing well on this show we talked about
mental health
wellness parenting relationships
marriage everything friendships all of
it um give me a shout if you want to be
on the show at
1-844-693-3291 that's
six 1-844-6900 three three two nine one
be on the show uh leave a message at the
tone old school style like 1985 and
kelly will listen to the message and
give you a shout back we'll go to
johndeloney.com
and uh
james
we have to talk about what happened this
past weekend
i'm still trying to come down off the
high and the disappointment of losing
we didn't win but our metal band
we rocked it james
we rocked it till the wheels fell off
i think we only started with two to
three wheels as as somebody in the crowd
with both hands up how
give us a spectator's ex part of the
experience kelly it was freaking awesome
it really was i mean for those that
don't know this is my era this is i was
a hair metal girl
you know an 80s rocker and it just
it warms my heart to hear james
singing the songs that he
pretty much has
turned his nose up at for like the last
eight years because he only likes fans
no one's heard of
and so to hear him sing and motley crew
and guns and roses and
def leppard just you have no idea what
it did for me i think it made us closer
it did there was a moment when james
came to practice one day and he's like
hey guys
we're going to do this metallica song
and i thought in my heart oh no we broke
james and i told kelly that i said kelly
i think we broke james and she said yes
and we rebuilt him back stronger
he's like the bionic fan now yeah
it was so phenomenal y'all were great
and i had so much fun james
hey just so you know james brought the
thunder number one
i'm not going to beat this into the
ground but he was straight up rock
rocking the gibson which is incredible
but dude you were all over the place man
i've never had that much fun playing
music before you were up on the like way
up on the speakers climbing up on stuff
it was incredible i've watched james at
battle of the bands now for
you know off and on for eight years and
i've never seen him like climb up on the
speakers and do all that kind of stuff
it was great i'm usually a shoegazer so
i think i came out of my yeah usually
just like jangling your fender jazz
master just thinking about sad poetry
about your dad and dude man the power of
def leppard i'm telling you
james
there was a moment i looked over and i
was just smiling ear to ear because that
was a lot that was super fun james had
this dope wig on it was incredible
anyway but we lost
to the guy who runs
the whole business part of my world cody
bennett and let's be honest he rocked it
he had some 90s country and he pretty
much
rolled the whole place up like an old
joint smoke that he was incredible he
was really good but i'm going to be
filing some voter fraud charges 100 well
on zach's
band what was that what were you guys
doing
partying
i strongly disagree i don't even know
what happened um
i don't know how to say train wreck in
spanish but if i could that's what i
would call it but it is what it is
voter fraud fake election what else can
we call it we'll start a new podcast
series where we dive into all the the
finer details of battle the band's drama
dude that's genius and especially the
voter fraud that's my subtle way of
telling you let's move on with the show
that wasn't very subtle i appreciate
that all right let's go to jermaine in
columbus ohio what's up jermaine
how's it going dr john dude we're
rocking on man how about you
we're doing well it's a beautiful day
excellent man what's up how can i help
yeah so first i just want to thank you
for in your team for the work that you
all do um i i love the book redefining
anxiety
my question is
you you often speak about the importance
of sleep
um in in regards of mental health but uh
you know i'm i am a father of uh four
kids under five and
uh
y'all are in it huh
yeah so we uh you know i'm also you know
trying to become financially secure and
debt free
and so i'm working a lot of hours and uh
that eight hour sleep is is not possible
so
where are some tools of sleep um
or quality of sleep is maybe not an
option
because of you know the mission that
is in front of us okay
so walk me through what a day looks like
for you are you married
yes i am married okay so walk me through
what a day looks like for you and your
spouse
well right now um
my spouse uh does stay home and so she
manages the household and uh you know i
i get up around six
uh go to my day job and um what's your
day job five
um
i i'm in transportation
or logistics so
um and
so it is a desk job um
which is fine and what are your hours
in that job
um it's 40 hour a week so you said you
get up at six to go to work and you work
till five
that's way more than yeah i wake up
well i wake up at six because i'm
getting ready that the kids are up
it does take me a little bit longer
to to get out the door but i typically
start at eight so
eight to five then uh in the evenings i
i work another seven hours at uh between
two other part-time jobs uh typically so
i i you know i was doing my schedule
this week i'm at 90 hours for the week
um
as in when it's planned so so what is
trying to get out of debt big time right
yeah y'all are all in it you got four
kids under the age of five your house is
a hurricane
your wife is working 90 hours a week
she's working 150 hours a week
um
and you're working 90 hours a week so i
just want to stop the presses right now
and high-five you okay you're not afraid
of hard work you are not
playing woe is me
you have a goal and y'all are trying to
do everything you can to get out of um
this this financial hole you're in how
much debt do you have
um we have
just over 60 grand
um and that's just a it's a a la carte
of of different things but
um it's definitely a target we can head
what kind of debt is it
uh it's it's
some is like credit line
uh student loans
um
and that's it's between credit like a
couple credit cards
in the car payment okay
and at the rate you're working
how long you until you pay this thing
off
um we're right now it's two and a half
years okay
so you're thinking about
working 90 hours a week for two and a
half years
and when you say you get off at five
o'clock
then what happens next
well today i'm driving straight to my
second job so there's commute times that
are included and not the 90 hours but
there there is a commute when do you see
yourself so
well thankfully you know with the you
know my day job i can work from home
every other week okay
i take advantage of that so i can be
present um i still
tried my best to show up for my son's
soccer games
um and i've been able to make that
happen so far
um and so i i you know especially with
the work from home option i'm able to
uh still be present um some weeks you
know there are some days it seems like
and in the mornings like i'm there when
they they wake up so
they see me every every but that is that
is also a factor there are some
stretches where it's just like
hey hi bye what are these other two jobs
you're working man
um they're they're they're also like uh
i guess
like
ones delivering pizzas or working at a
pizza shop and the other one is
uh packing boxes with smiles on them
okay very cool so is there a possibility
and i'm just shooting the dark here
before i get into the sleep stuff
is there a
what do you make delivering pizzas
like give me a monthly guess
well that one i i just picked that up uh
and the reason why i just picked it up
because it's closer home so half the
week i can kind of
i don't have a commute time um and it's
a hybrid so i'm in in the shop
like an assistant manager role and then
on the road so i don't have a good solid
number
right now and i apologize for that don't
apologize man it's cool give me a guess
though brother
i i would say um
that's just sorry i'm kind of analytical
so i i'm not
i don't have enough data to say yes but
or to give you a good guess but so why'd
you take the job
well
to get closer to home i need to make
with
you know my extra my extra side job i'm
able to make is bring home like an
additional
650 per week so that's that's
between the two side jobs that's the
goal i'm aiming for okay
and so was it was about another 2500 a
month
on top of yeah okay
and so then you get home
and
you crash
you you say you work another seven hours
so you're working till what midnight
um sometimes like well actually zero
like zero two
okay
and then you're getting up at six
o'clock and doing it all over again
yep between six and six thirty i'm not
perfect
like that okay
you should be perfect i'm just kidding
man it's all good you're like beating
yourself up dude
um how long you been doing this
well that's that's also another factor
um it's i've been up at this tempo
probably for a year um
on and off i need to be more i like it's
probably
inconsistently
three years
but we keep
we we've added more children to the mix
so
um it seems like i we keep starting over
how much do you make in your day job
uh
like 45
uh annually so not it's it's that
i i've been interviewing and trying to
improve that yeah um
and that's that's the that's the big
opportunity right there to solve is this
to increase that dollar amount so here's
what i'll tell you i've led teams of
i'm trying to think even my last one was
i think it was 12 13 14 direct reports
who then had their own direct reports
down through the student employees
hundreds of people in the division that
i i was responsible for
and what i'll tell you is i would bend
over backwards to hire somebody like you
based on your work ethic alone
you are not scared of work
you want to take care of your family you
want to take care of your kids
you are not afraid to bust it busted
busted
and i think that you can be making more
than 45 000 a year
okay so this is not why you called this
is just a side note
i would love for you to connect with my
buddy ken coleman and go through his um
he's got a new new book coming out
that's incredible in fact i'll give you
a copy of it stay on the line when we
get done and i'm gonna have kelly send
you a copy of ken's new book
um from paycheck to purpose it's got a
lot of tools on figuring out what it is
you do best and then how to get paid for
what you do best
okay you've got the desire in your soul
man and that's such a rare thing
um
i want you to get a bigger shovel to get
out of this mess so then getting to them
to the mess
the same as when you look at by the way
for people wondering like what does this
have to do with relationships mental
health
i am a firm believer firm believer
if you owe somebody money
your body registers that as a trauma
because you are not in control of your
life
you are not safe
if you owe somebody money because they
get to dictate what you do every day
they get to dictate where you live
because they're dictating how much you
have to pay off every month
you're not in control of where your
paycheck goes because you're paying for
last month's stuff to try to get ahead
and so one of the
basic
mental health 101s is to solve for
freedom where am i not safe
where am i not in control of my destiny
and if you owe somebody money
you're not safe
if you owe somebody money you're not in
control of your destiny so that's why
this matters and i'm really grateful
that you called
just like a math problem
when you got to live on a budget right
and you are overspending your budget
it's the same with sleep
you are in fight or flight right now you
are as as dave ramsey buddy says um
you're being gazelle intense you're
trying to work three jobs run as fast as
you can to get this debt paid off so
y'all can breathe is that right
yes okay
when you're in when a gazelle is running
for its life from a lion trying to eat
it
it will
twist an ankle it will crash into things
it will get soaking wet it will get cut
on sticks and rocks and it keeps
sprinting and sprinting the goal isn't
wellness the goal is to live
to survive
okay
you're there right now
i think you've put undue pressure on
yourself because you're making 45 grand
i want to see you make more money than
that but right now you're in a season
the math on sleep doesn't change
if you're not getting seven to eight
hours sleep you're not going to be your
full self and what i'll tell you is over
time you're going to
you're going to get a net negative
return you're already there by the way a
net negative return on your mental
health on your physical health on your
work productivity on your ability to be
a dad and a present husband
i will also tell you for a year
for two years man two years max
hit the gas on it
but after that man you are going to run
smack dab into the wall of physiological
reality
and that can look like taking a couple
of days and only working one day job
that can look like getting a new job
that can look like several different
things but brother you've got to be
connected to your wife you got to be
connected to those kids and you got to
sleep
you got to move your body and you know
those things right
yes that's the challenge i i know that
but i also know what the numbers look
like and
so it's that uh
like the duty to to make sure i take
care of and i know within you know two
or three years our as long as we have no
more children um
you know there's a there's a couple of
different things y'all can do there
we're researching it yes um don't even
have to research it man it's just it's
pretty straightforward
um no i underst i understand um but you
know i know that
you know it's not gonna be you know part
sometimes some days i feel like man this
is the next you know because there's
always going to be expenses uh you know
just even having you know our son play
soccer go to school there's just all
kinds of hidden expenses that come with
that sometimes
uh especially with the first child going
through um we're being exposed to that
and then thinking about college and
things down the road so
um you know but there's been times where
the reason why i said in the previous
years i've had to hit stop in the second
job because i just couldn't i couldn't
do it because we hit gas anymore that's
right um like you know i was in a fog um
so and so what i was saying so two
things one
you were running like mad and i don't
feel like your your destination is
solidified
you've got some ideas and one of the
ideas is sprint like crazy
another one of the ideas is we want to
be have no debt we don't want to owe
anybody anything
the rest of it feels
still kind of fuzzy
and so how can you balance being a dad
being present
and at the same time grinding and
grinding and sprinting and how can you
balance getting a new job but it pays
you more money
how can you find if there's if pizza and
if you're what i'm telling you is you
can't do four hours for that many more
years
and you've experienced it you know that
right
yes
what i don't want you to do is to begin
to think about um
college to begin to think about i mean
you got to think about those things but
right now you are running for your life
and if you're running for your life and
you're also wondering huh what if we're
gonna put a back deck on someday
dude you're gonna crash
you'll crash
so here's what i want you to do okay
i want you to
um get with your wife
and y'all may have done this recently
but i want you to get with your wife
and take stock of the last 12 months
how much debt have you all paid off how
much money have you actually made with
these other jobs
what kind of job would you have to get
would have to be a 65 000 year job
a 75 to make up for the two incomes of
the two jobs you're running and gunning
with
what would it look like for her to pick
up a side hustle and i know you've got
four kids i get it um
is that possible
but i want you to reverse engineer where
you're going and not just run
wild gazelles and deer when they're
running away from a predator
they run in a direction they run towards
safety they run
in with it
on a path they don't just run haphazard
all over the field in figure eights
until they just collapse and get eaten
okay
again what your kids are lucky to have
you man a dad that is just
leveling up leveling up i'll do anything
it takes to pay this debt off to give
them a future that i didn't have to take
care of my i'll do anything to put food
on the table to make sure they're
playing soccer going to college good for
you good for you
i want your
path from where you are now to debt
freedom to be a much straighter line as
my old track coach zoe simpson used to
say
the fastest place between point and
point b is a straight line
and i want you to level out that energy
and the same as we can't change the math
on
a budget and how much money you make and
how much debt you have i can't change
the math on sleep
you can gut it out for a season and i
recommend people do that if you're
solving for safety i recommend you gut
it out gut it out cut it out cut it out
but you can't do that for three four
five years
can't sprint like that you can't go on
four hours of sleep for that long your
body will break down the science is just
super clear about that you gotta
exercise you gotta see sunlight you've
got to be with your kids
and um
you deserve that man your family
deserves that everybody deserves that so
get with your wife
let's get some real numbers and some
real ar articulate it and let's work
backwards come up with a game plan
brother you've got this got this god
this is just gonna we're gonna
straighten this line out and man you
gotta sleep you gotta sleep you gotta
sleep all right we'll be right back on
the doctor john dolone's show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody and it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john doloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we're back hey before
you keep going
i'm just curious if you've ever watched
the discovery channel because
that's what you describe gazelles
running around in circles until they
tire out and get eaten yeah that's
literally exactly what does happen
they run all over the place and they
tire out and then the cheetah eats them
so i think your metaphor still has
merits but i just wanted to clear up
some of the
you're such a pro science guy and you're
not really
kelly
i'd like to congratulate you on your new
promotion you are now the senior
producer of the john doloni show uh
before you say that we were laughing
about it because you you were wrong
that's exactly how nature works so but
listen is there not i've changed i've
seen deer in the woods and i spook them
when i'm hunting and they run in a laser
straight line away from me it's not like
there's base somewhere and then if they
get there the cheetah can't eat them
they just run this first sucks i hate
this show
you're dear
new podcast deer are different than like
gazelle in the savannah but yeah they
just run until hopefully the the cheetah
finds something else to do hang on a
second hey jermaine we're back
are you still there
i am evidently i'm an idiot
so
here's the thing during the break
kelly and james told me that uh
gazelle's just running circles until
until they get eaten they deserve to not
be in the gene pool more on animals they
just run in figure eights and
loop-de-loops until the lion catches
them
is that really what happens
i mean not all the time but a lot of
times that's that's cheetahs run for a
long time
so that they tire out the animals yeah
that's kind of how it works now that we
don't have band practice anymore we'll
get together and watch some nature shows
and see how it works well you just made
this weird james so jermaine forget
everything i just said and i'm just
gonna tell you you need to get some
sleep dude
at some point
you got to get some sleep do the roi is
the pizza job that you're making every
month
worth that much sleep
just do the roi on that and never ever
watch a nature show ever again
and hopefully the next podcast you call
into the guy will be smarter on
how hoofed animals escape predators
yali y'all are the worst
not you jermaine you're my friend hey if
there's any openings when you're looking
for a new job holler at your boy dude
i'll send you my email address off on
the internets and i'll be your co-worker
we'll wreck shop wherever it is you're
gonna get a job at
these two guys all right hey have a good
one jermaine stay in school don't do
drugs all that stuff
all right we're gonna go to mary and see
if i can do a better job with mary
uh hey mary and tacoma what's up
um hey there um i love how you all rise
each other so much it's very
entertaining it's not entertaining
listen
listen evidently james got his doctorate
in zoology over the weekend after our
band failed and
particularly in uh
animal
animal gps animal movement
[Laughter]
animal i don't even know what you would
what do you call that animal travel
common
common sense oh here we go here comes
kelly with her wisdom
all right mary so what's up how can i
help please no no no talking about
animals let's move on okay
um we're talking about people now so
good um a couple of weeks ago um my 15
year old daughter
just seemed like i was the only one
still awake everybody was asleep and she
came in the kitchen and
started crying and was you know just
saying that she was overwhelmed with
school and all her sports and everything
and
you know just not kind of
uncharacteristic of her to to be like
that but she does have sports every day
and school's a heavy load now that
they're all back in person and
we kind of talked a little bit about
that and got through that
i just said hey is there anything else
that's going on with you and
she goes yeah there's some things i need
to talk to you about and i was like well
let's go sit down on the couch hey hello
you you knew it was coming didn't you
i think i did yeah you do did you super
i know it's coming and i wasn't even
there
okay so hold on just for every parent of
a young kid you're about to get the
reverse talk which is all it's a worse
nightmare than the original talk and oh
yeah is your heart racing
like put everybody in your head in your
body when this was going on um
i think i expected this conversation at
some point but not this near this thing
and how old again i am kind of like
freaking out a little bit
but i was like okay we're gonna we're
gonna we're we were standing in the
kitchen so i'm like we're gonna go sit
down
everybody else is asleep we can have a
good time right now
and
completely dark in the house
in the my 15 year old daughter 15
15. okay
okay
and
um
just to prep everybody for what's about
to come is that
she's been dating this boy who we really
love
for
probably about nine months
and
she
proceeded to tell me that they have had
sexual intercourse and i
i i was i maybe wasn't expecting that
part maybe i was expecting just
hey we've done some things and i'm so
glad that she feels open enough to even
talk to me about it right yeah okay hey
before we go further i just want to
pause there um that tells me that you've
got a great relationship with your
daughter so high five to you that's
that's a big deal um one of the
i think we can all
it's a mirage it's a it's a it's a myth
it's a fantasy to think that our kids
are going to get through
any
middle school high school call without
challenges and the greatest gift you can
give your kid is the gift to trust that
when they find themselves over their
head or underwater
they'll reach out to you so good for you
that's awesome that's years and years of
you being a trustworthy person that she
came to you so that's great
well and i yeah like i said i just feel
so fortunate that that is the case
because
you know i mean i don't think i would
have ever had the guts to talk to my mom
about that
when i was her age
i've got two kids and me and my mom
still don't talk about that so yeah i'm
i mean well no i mean well that's kind
of a generational thing yeah actually we
do talk about it way too much in my
family but um anyway okay so you're in
the i'm trying to set the stage of
what's what almost a lifetime movie so
it goes from
reaching out in the kitchen to an in the
dark conversation and walk me through
what she's telling you here
so she tells me that and she said i
you know
i feel like she goes
you know
i think we need to talk about birth
control
and i said well yeah that does come
along with sexual intercourse and i said
but
let's kind of backtrack a little bit
because
a i want to make sure that you
feel safe with this person and then i
also want to make sure that you're not
being pressured into doing something
that you're not ready for
and she was like no i don't feel
pressured at all and then that really
just kind of sends off alarm bells
because i'm like
i kind of wanted her to feel pressured
right
[Music]
and
she
it's not that she seemed fine with it
i think more than anything because she
said to me later she goes i'm just
worried you're going to think less of me
what was your response to that
i said
honey i would never
think less of you i said
i think more of you because you've come
to me to talk about it yeah
that's awesome and
and and really we
we just kind of talked through
and and i've had this talk with her
before just because even before the
boyfriend
my parents never had open conversations
with me about sex and so i was like i'm
gonna be different with my kids
and i said to her you know
when she started high school is that you
know
you may become interested in boys and
they're definitely interested in girls
and
we kind of talked about all the things
that can happen and i don't want you to
ever feel pressured
and
also talked about what a big deal
sex is
emotionally and
how it really takes some maturity and
she
you know asked me a lot of questions
about
when was the first time i did were you
honest
i was totally honest with her awesome
but i was
i just graduated from high school and
yeah i was probably still pretty
immature
at the time
but
so i i guess that's why i never dreamed
i'd be having the conversation with her
this early yeah
[Music]
so how can i help you
so
moving forward i mean you know
the main thing that i made clear to her
is that
uh and i didn't say this directly to her
but
what i was thinking in my head is that
you just said that here's what you just
said
i made this super clear to her i didn't
really say it but you know what i mean
this is my head
i know how that sounds but
in my head i'm thinking to myself you
know
uh
you can always i just said a situation
if you ever feel like this isn't working
or
that you
don't want to be doing this anymore
you don't have to do that you know you
can step back and and if this boy isn't
into that then he can hit the road
and she was she was like mom i know that
and she goes and i just want you to know
that my boyfriend has
been so respectful of me and
and
has never pressured me
and you know
of course they think they're in love
with each other as we all do with our
first
sure boyfriend or girlfriend
um
and i'm just so worried about her heart
being broken even more i just know for
me
um once you put sex into the equation it
changes everything
so mary um
i know you know this
but your 15 year old's a child
yes
and i mean she doesn't even have a
freaking license to drive a car and that
that's what's gonna go as a society
we've all put our heads together and
said you know what 15 year olds are too
young to even drive
yeah 15 year olds are too young to buy
cigarettes they're too young to buy beer
they're tuned to buy
um
guns like we've put these restrictions
on
children
because
they make decisions based on connection
they make decisions on what feels good
right now they make decisions
that aren't thought out or wise
and that's why they desperately need
parents
and
this puts you in an incredibly awkward
position because the whole thing is
predicated on trust right
right and we often back trust up to you
promise you won't tell and you promise
that
you
it's two of two things one you promise
you won't tell and
you promise you'll stand by with
whatever it is i'm doing and anything
beyond that is perceived as a violation
of trust and what i would say to you as
a parent and any parent dealing with
this
is
to
go one step beneath
this conversation
and look at your child reaching out
saying will you please help me will you
please protect me from myself
and that is a level of trust that is not
going to be
um
is not going to be at the forefront of a
15 year old brain which is why
she's got a mom
and
um
it's going to feel it's going to feel
yucky in the moment but
the thing she desperately needs is her
mom to step up and be mom
not best friend not older sister not
right we'll make good choices 15 year
olds can't make good choices because
they're 15.
you know what i mean
i i completely agree with you
so
i just need your advice on the best way
to direct that aside from forbidding
them to see each other you know i as you
said i want to maintain that level of
trust with her
and the reality is is that
both of them are going to be driving in
a few months
and if they continue to date then
you know i
so i'm going to tell you something crazy
all right okay and this fits in i've had
this conversation with
atheist sex secular
um
researchers
i've had this with
super jesus freak counselors and pastors
and everyone in between
15 year olds too young given sex 16 17
year olds too young to be having sex
yeah they can create a human
they can um
they can it
i'm not going to go through the risks we
all know that stuff we're all grown up
right
the risks are immeasurable and we don't
let them take this type of risk with
anything else
and so what trust is going to look like
now what parenting is going to look like
now
is going to feel like a violation to a
15 year old
and it's going to be something that
comes along down the road
when your kid circles back and says
i'm so thankful that fill in the blank
that you cared enough about me
and it will be hard and it will be tears
and it will be use promised and i can't
believe you i hate you it'll be all that
stuff and there's seasons when that's
what parents have to take
yeah
but i have not met
the mental health professional
secular faith-based atheist
lunatic and we all know lunatic mental
health practitioners i haven't met the
one that's like yeah 15 year olds that's
great that's cool just make good choices
i haven't met them
because they're children
they can't make those kind of choices
and so
if my 16 year old kids are in that same
boat they're not driving
i'm taking them places
the same way as if i knew they were
sneaking alcohol or they were doing
drugs or they were
filling the blanket any other risky
behavior that a 15 year old or 16 year
old stem cell doesn't have the brain
capacity to to to deal with
and you and i both know what adult sex
how that much that complicates stuff
it's complicated in marriage
much less
you know what i mean trying to figure
out what your body's doing yeah
and so all that to say is there is
you've heard me say before you know not
by your hand but in your lap your baby
girl so gracefully came and dropped us
in your lap
and i want you to hear it both as an
honoring of the parenting up until now
and a deep cry for help
okay
and it's gonna be so hard so hard
there's not an easy way out i'd
recommend calling his parents he's too
young to be having sex he's 15.
yeah
and bringing everybody in on it and your
daughter will go bananas
you know what i mean have you talked to
him about it yeah
i have not
and
um
but i do know the parents were getting
to know them better um
you're about to get to them real real
well yeah yeah
and here's the thing you don't hate your
kids 15 year old sex is awesome 15 year
olds they're being 15. you know what i
mean
so they're not bad or broken they're 15.
and then suddenly they found themselves
over their heads
yeah and that's why they need us to step
in
no and i do think i mean it's
if i if i bring his parents in i mean
it's really going to only help
strengthen that they they're a great
family
strong ties with their kids
from what i know of them they're great
parents
um
and just good people yeah and so
uh you know i
i know it's not like if i go to them
and to their son to talk about it
that they're not going to you know brush
me off and say you know
pound sand
and here's the thing even if they did
even if you knew that was coming who
cares
you can only control you right and so if
they're going to tell you that you're an
idiot i can't believe you're calling us
they're just kids let them have fun
that's your decision and then it's your
daughter to protect
it's awesome that they're gonna they
they might potentially partner with you
on this
um the the big thing here is to make
sure your kids don't feel dirty or gross
or that they're somehow evil you know
what i mean and they may internalize
that and feel that great and here's the
other thing
if they want to have sex they'll figure
out a place to do it that's true right
they can get pretty creative
your job isn't to
i don't know
you don't create a police state at the
same time i'm going to do what i can in
my power to make sure my kids are safe
yeah
i'm going to make sure they're safe and
15 year olds having sex are not safe
for a hundred different reasons
yeah and so
does this surprise you that i'm saying
this or did you know this was coming and
you didn't you wanted me to say
something i mean really if you're you're
just a reinforcing voice that i needed
to hear
and i think part of the issue is that um
things are really crazy in the state
that i live in as you may be aware
for example
if i take my daughter to the
pediatrician
i can only come into the room with her
permission that's right
at 13.
is when that starts yeah
um
and so i mean you know she could have
just gone to our pediatrician and never
told me anything
um
and so you know i
i i think about that and i
just hearing what you said re i mean it
reinforces what our family's values are
not only that
but also
where i need to take it from here and
you know i mean
yeah i want to be supportive of her and
know
that
she knows that we love her no matter
what but at the same time that our job
as parents is to keep her safe yeah
that's that's a line that i use in my
house since my kids were born in
anticipation of this very conversation
someday
uh and multiple other ones but my jobs
keep you safe do the best i can and i
can't keep you safe for forever
two things that i hear a lot from
parents in this situation one like you
mentioned
i was sexually active as a teenager too
and either a it was awesome it was fine
nothing happened or b
i was pressured to do stuff i wasn't
comfortable with and i don't want to
talk to my kids about that
and so
either way your shame your
bad experience or your guilt that you
kind of it was kind of awesome and
here we are in a dif it's a different
planet with cell phones and everyone's
got cameras the whole thing is at
another level
same as like i've heard back smoking
weed in the 70s there's one thing
smoking weeds now with his high power
it's just different things are different
and understanding that we're on a
different planet and i tell you what if
i'd had a cell phone with a camera as a
15 year old i would be forever
unemployable forever you know what i
mean
i would it would be a whole different
i can't even wrap my head around that
that's number one number two
you're right
you live in a state where
middle schoolers can go in
and leave their parents out of medical
decisions
that doesn't mean you stop parenting or
throw your hands up
and you do keep that relationship and if
your daughter
wants to
move off the grid in that kind of in
that way
and your state supports that there's all
kinds of other conversations you all
need to have about where you live and
what your values are
most of the time
most of the time
kids default to that connected
relationship
and they do not they will kick and
scream against accountability but deep
down they go
oh thank god i'm safe
i'm still wired in here
and that's why it's so important to
shame your kid for wanting to
be physically active with somebody and
they're ki of course they do it's
awesome
and that's why they need parents that
are going to love them walk alongside
them and say i'm putting up boundaries
because you're 15.
um
and yeah if your daughter goes and gets
birth control from a doctor and sneaks
it behind your back and you never find
out about it
there's not a whole lot you can do about
that until you until you do find out
about it
and again i'm not suggesting a police
state i am suggesting a heightened level
of awareness and a heightened level of
parental involvement
and making sure every parent's on the
same page and i'm not going to leave my
kid alone in my house i'm not going to
go out of town and let them stay at the
play i'm going to i'm going to be more
present a lot more present
all under the guise of i'm gonna keep my
kids safe i'm gonna keep my kids safe
i love you too much to
let you get over your head and or
underwater are the same thing right
um it's a tough road to hoe you got for
you but you have built up so many years
of relational connection there
and um
the play is now five years 10 years 15
years down the road that you loved your
daughter enough to step in and say hey
hey it's my job to help you stay safe
and it's gonna be uncomfortable for
everybody but i love you too much too
just say all right make good choices
[Music]
she's lucky to have you she's lucky to
have you mary we'll be right back on the
dr john dolone's show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndalone.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back oh look we have a
zoologist who's going to teach us how
deer run
just kidding we don't
no if i just beat that joke in the
ground now
not yet
[Laughter]
no john you can just keep on going let's
go to ann in
wolves kentucky
what's up ann
hi dr john how are you today remarkable
and you
uh i'm great here in louisville
louisville louisville louisville
what's up how are you not much so um
i just wanted to call uh thanks for
chatting with me today but right now um
i'm just struggling with managing my
work-life balance and my family life
i'm finding a lot of value in the work i
do and the hours i spend at work but i
feel like i'm jeopardizing a lot of my
family life because i focus so much on
work
and i'm seeking your guidance i guess on
how i redirect this and how i find
balance i think balance is a myth what
do you think when you think of balance i
don't think it's real i think it's a and
it's a it's a fantasy it's not real
but people have a picture in their head
of what it's supposed to look like what
does your picture look like
so in that perfect world i think would
be 50 50 but we're finding you know as
you go day by day that's certainly not
possible or it doesn't feel possible
realistically when you're actually doing
it
um
but it would be great if i could you
know
split my time 50 50 or even 60 family 40
work life balance but
right now in the past i'm i'm taking it
just doesn't feel like that's doable
so
something has kept you from
pulling the trigger either way what is
it
you know i think really right now what
it is is i'm just
i struggle with my self-worth
and i think i find a lot of myself worth
in the amount of work i do
not so much
in the quality of work i do and i think
that's just honesty when
we get down you know to the core of it i
think
it's how much can i do today it's not
you know stepping away and
you know promoting that healthy
work-life balance it's just
how much can i do i almost get manic
about it i think it's the best way to
describe it where's that come
from gosh i i think so
when i was younger i was at 11 i was
diagnosed with anorexia and so
i always kind of correlated with that i
guess
i have to find
um
i don't know i have to focus on
something to not focus on that like i
have to
really
concentrate on something hard to kind of
get those negative feelings out of my
head if that makes sense the negative
you mean the the anorexic demons calling
you or just the sense that you're not
enough you don't look right you don't
play right you're not a good enough this
you're not good enough of that
i think at a deeper level it's probably
i'm not a good enough whatever it is
that day so
sometimes that comes out in food
sometimes that comes at my relationship
with my child
and my husband
but a lot of times it comes out you know
in my relationships at work and
you know
in the work i do um i'm a property
manager so i mean it's 600 units so it's
every day it's something but it's
i've been you know even told by my
supervisors you need to learn when to
turn it off but it's like i don't have
that often
so tell me if this sounds right and also
tell me if i'm wrong okay i've been told
i'm wrong several times on the show by
kelly and james so feel free to hop in
um
how much of it is you can control things
at work you're good at what you do you
know how to solve problems and that is a
hurricane that you can grab the tale of
and control it
and when you look in the eyes of your
little kid
and you look in the eyes of your husband
there's a recklessness and a strength to
that love that is
uncontrollable and it feels out of your
grasp
and it's simply safer for your heart and
your body and your soul to go back to
work because i know the rules there and
i know a plus b equals c
because love is a risk
and i can't control that risk does that
sound right or my way off
no that that's exactly right i think
that's absolutely correct i think it's
you know when i'm at work it's it's
i don't want to say it's easy but it it
just makes sense and it's easy to
control certain situations
and then at home it's like
hostile sometimes and it's
high emotions and it's high stress and
not that work isn't but
so where does that stress at home come
from do you bring it home or is your
husband a jerk or you just have a
two-month-old that's just bananas like
where does it come from
i think my husband and i
we both work very high demand jobs we
both he's in school full time
you know i work 60 70 hours a week on a
good week um and then we come home and
we we bring all of that high anxiety
home
and that's what our three-year-old thing
of course so then i wonder how it's
affecting him long term he's three
he's three and he's so he's always
seeing these two super stressed out
parents yeah so what i would tell you is
he's not seeing it
there's actually some research dr gabor
mate
he is absorbing that at the genetic
level
yeah it's becoming part of him
how mommy and dad talk to one another
how they interact with one another how
they are courtesy and serve one another
how they love one another how they touch
each other how they look and laugh
he's absorbing that
and it has epigenetic um consequences
both up and down
he's not just watching it he's absorbing
it
um
so
christy again my friend christopher and
stay on the line here um kelly's gonna
send you a copy of her brand new book
take back your time it's on this exact
topic
um
she does a great job of
this idea of seasons
versus balance balance is bullcrap it's
not real and it's a myth sold to you by
every
the name of the game and selling is
i have to convince you that you're
missing a thing so that i you'll buy my
thing right
and
if there's this myth of balance life
never feels 50 50.
and so we just pathologically add stuff
to either side of that scale trying to
get it to balance up and then just as
always stays wonky
so i'm going to buy a new
i'm going to sign up for a yoga class
but that takes time so then i'm going to
um get a bunch of new fancy pots and
pans because we're going to cook
together and that doesn't work so then
i'm going to
you know you mean you're always just
teeter-tottering on this thing
and
instead of looking at it 50 50 balance
look at the season so your husband's
working a demanding job and he's in
school full-time is that right yes yes
and you have a three-year-old
yes
so ann you're working 70 hours a week in
a job that you're really good at
probably weren't put on earth to be a
property manager maybe you were
but you're kicking butt in it and they
say hey way to go but even your boss is
like how about we take 30 off how do we
dial it back a little bit and you're
like never
never exactly
so
um the conversation and she's got some
stuff in her book that's great that um
you can work through with your husband
but
it's just taking a breath and saying
okay we're in a season right now
like i'm in that same season too it's
the fall i'm on the road a lot i'm
speaking my wife's got a book coming out
she's working on retreats and all kind
of stuff she's also a professor she's
getting flown to another state to teach
because she's so good at it
it's bananas in our house and i got a
sixth grader and a kindergartner
and so we're in a season and we
over-committed and most of it's my fault
but we over committed and so we're
saying okay what's it gonna look like
till december this isn't this fake 50 50
because that's not real
what's it gonna look like to get through
christmas and then what's our spring
gonna look like cause that's what we can
control we've already signed up for
stuff this fall and so y'all are in a
bonkers season what is life going to
look like where can we extract joy out
of the season that we're in
and what i want you all to do is come up
with a map for what this season is going
to look like and then the spring will
look like and here's going to be your
adventure right now
your adventure is when you get home and
you start to feel that
whatever take off in your body i want
you to be really intentional about
writing down where it is
do you feel your chest start to get
tight do you feel your stomach drop do
you feel your necks start to get start
to hurt i want you to begin to feel it
in your body and now be mad at yourself
and don't judge yourself i can't believe
this i
i want you to start being really curious
with anne
like what's my body trying to protect me
from right now
what am i missing here is it sleep is it
connection with my with my kid and i
know getting on all fours and playing is
so fun but it's so boring
but what am i missing here
when's the last time me and my husband
had sex it was great it wasn't just this
duty checklist thing that that we found
actual like
joy we were like really into one another
for more than one night maybe it's two
or four or so what what when's the last
time we were intimately connected for a
season right once you begin to have
those conversations together and with
yourself start to experience where the
stuff is in your body
do you think you and in fact i was just
reading a meta-analysis on eating
disorders the other day and the
prognosis that what they don't know
is just mind-boggling to me
um did you
did you heal from childhood stuff or are
you still playing are you still running
um
i think i'm still running you know i
i do um i just got out of there really
bad i guess we could say i got i got
over a really bad relapse i don't think
you ever get over it but i thought
you know
it started to creep its
its head back in right around the time
and turn two okay and
what was going on in your world
was intimacy at an all-time low was
husband gone were you stressed at work
what was going on at home
i
i think at home our life was completely
chaotic my husband and i were fighting
all the time
we had fundamental disagreements
regarding money and regarding how we
wanted to run our household
we just purchased a home which naturally
brings stress into the equation
um
and
you know we're trying to deal with both
both sides of our emotions
and raising a three-year-old and i think
you know with covet and everything going
on there was no physical escape my
physical escape became work you know
what was left of it during that time and
um so it almost felt like you for me i
had no control over anything in my
household like i didn't have control
over my relationship with my husband it
was so toxic at that time and we've been
in therapy and we've
you know and that's been great we're
doing much better now but everything
just seemed very chaotic in our lives
and you can control that right
yes that's part of the challenge is
figuring out how to do that because
there was a point i think during all of
that that we could that we didn't feel
we could but
um
no i'm saying i'm saying your body began
to say oh i remember i remember
something i can control
yes um and it's so
it's not funny but it's ironic because
when you try to explain eating disorders
to people who don't understand such as
my husband who's never been around it
i'm like you know it's totally
unconscious unconscious like i don't i
don't think about it i just fall back
into these habits and then one day
things calm down and
i think about it again and i'm like okay
i am falling back down that down that
rabbit hole and you kind of have to pull
yourself back up because
you don't even realize you're losing the
control when you are yeah and it can be
yeah it can be disassociative that's
right so a couple things one i'm gonna
send you that book okay i don't want you
to ever say work life balance ever again
as long as you live
okay i want you to start thinking in
seasons and sometimes in the winter it's
just really cold and you got to wear
jackets you don't go outside so much
and or you got to go outside and you
know it's going to be cold out there and
then sometimes it's summer and it's
really hot
but you go to the pool
and you dress differently and same in
the spring and same in the fall
life rolls in seasons
not in balance
we've been sold a lie it's not real and
so i want to give you this book i want
you to read it closely and it's brand
new it's the number one bestseller just
came out the other day um it's
incredible and christy is a great friend
i i want you to do the exercises in that
book you and your husband and counseling
i want you to be highly intentional
about telling your counselor
i'm struggling with this and i'm ready
for the first time
in years
to set this down and you're right the
the quote unquote ever be done with it
um
i both understand the data and the data
like the research is clear
it's hard to say i'm ever over
um anorexia that's tough
and i also believe
deeply in people setting these bricks
down in healing and it just doesn't come
back anymore
and that's highly intentional getting
connected with your body and what your
body's trying to tell you on a regular
basis
it sounds like what your body's telling
you right now and has been for a while
that your most important relationships
are not whole right now with your
husband
with your kid
and you are in fight or flight and
probably have been for years
and you are running to work because you
can control that
you are
disassociating yourself you're
distancing yourselves a better word from
the relationships because those hurt
and they're not solid right now
and it may be that he's got time for him
to step away from school for a season
for the sake of his marriage and his
family
it may mean that he can't work full-time
and y'all got to make some pretty
serious financial sacrifices and he's
going to go to school full-time and
you're going to make this for a season
until he gets out of school and then
he's going to go back to the workforce
full-time
it may mean that you step back
and say i'm going to lock eyes with this
three-year-old and this three-year-old's
going to be my world or maybe your
husband quits everything and he locks
eyes with this three-year-old whatever
that looks like the pace y'all are on is
unsustainable
and you know that
your kid feels that and your husband
knows it and now it's this weird dance
this weird game of chicken and which
one's going to cave first and if one of
you loses you both lose
and so the conversation has got to be
leveled up here um
and you've got to be highly intentional
about what this season's gonna look like
being intentional and direct about
planning for next season and something's
gonna have to give in the next season
somebody's gonna have to give in the
next season
and i'm convinced if you get serious
about not to say you haven't been
serious if you get highly intentional
and submit and vulnerable to healing
from anorexia i'm convinced you can i
know you can
you're too strong
you're too
brilliant i know you can i know no no
you can
and it's time now it's been exhausting
and it's time
thank you so much for this call and stay
on the line here and um
we will um we'll get you that book sent
out
never everybody never say the word
work-life balance not real it's a season
it's a season
life goes in rhythms and in seasons
identify the season you're in some
seasons are sprint seasons like our
first caller trying to get paid get get
out of debt
some seasons are we build trust we build
trust like the second caller build trust
we build trust we build trust
and then
man we got to have a season of winter we
got some hard accountability with our 15
year old we're gonna have to really
change how we parent how we interact
it's going to be hard
and then there will be other seasons of
spring the sun will come up again the
flowers will bloom
we'll have a difference we'll have a
different season
but knowing where you're at not trying
to balance it all balance and i'll
balance it all and we love you man we're
standing behind you call me every step
of the way if we can help okay time to
get serious about your marriage time to
get serious about parenting serious
about healing your heart
all right as we wrap up today's show i
got a couple of songs here these are uh
during a break james brought in this
song
i'm gonna read it it's about cheetahs
and gazelles
and lions
not really but i get the geographic
humor james
i crack myself up
do what
i crack myself up kelly
i'm gonna congratulate you again on your
new promotion it's incredible
james i hear they're hiring for
i don't know
cafeteria people downstairs
get the resume ready
not really i'll go work for national
geographic man
yeah
mapping out uh predatory escape patterns
the song is the classic
by toto
it's called africa
a little geography humor i get it
hope you get it america it goes like
this
i hear the drums echoing tonight but she
only hears whispers of some quiet
conversation she's coming in 12 30
flight her moonlit wings reflect the
stars that guide me towards salvation i
stopped an old man along the way
hoping to find some old forgotten words
or ancient melodies he was running in
jagged patterns like cheetahs evidently
do instead of straight lines away from
lions
he turned to me as if to say hurry boy
it's waiting there for you what is this
song about i bless the reigns this is
song's madness i bless the reigns down
in africa gonna take some time to do
things we never had what
run she to run straight lines run
this is the dr john dolone show